guys oh my god oh my god I've invested
in Bitcoin I've invested in fake coin
alright guys so everyone's talking about
this Bitcoin stuff I'm seeing it online
news reports videos supposedly it's like
a new online currency that someone
invented I didn't know you could invent
a currency anyway it's it's huge people
are becoming millionaires off this
millionaires I want to be a millionaire
it's a good place to start would be
figuring out what the Bitcoin is so I'm
going to reach out to a few people who
know a lot about Bitcoin and see if they
can give me any information or meet with
me so that I can be confident in my
investment and make a bunch of money
this video would be so much better if I
had someone filming me get like a really
cool shot real quick like a round like
I'm like I look like I'm doing something
important I was actually able to get in
touch with an 18 year old Bitcoin
millionaire and I'm game plan is I'm
gonna walk him by this little snack
section there's chips there's candy
there's coffee there soda ice cream I'm
gonna feed him whatever he wants and
then he's just gonna think I'm his best
friend and then I'm gonna have a bunch
of bitcoins and then I'm gonna be a
billionaire I'm actually kind of nervous
nice to meet you nice to meet you a
wonderful name yeah you like the name I
like the name and we have a big problem
you're Erik with a K so the better one
than me no no no I'm gonna take you to
my favorite spot immediately yeah all
right so these are the snacks or
anything you know
all right just introduce yourself to the
people who don't know who you are I am
Eric Finland I'm one of the youngest
Bitcoin millionaires and I am Eric Tuvok
and I'm one of the youngest BuzzFeed
presents so what is Bitcoin
so Bitcoin is like this virtual currency
so normally you have things like the US
dollar or the pound Bitcoin is just this
application the software that that
people choose to participate in and
people kind of like eBay choose to buy
it at a certain rate and people bit up
the certain rate or bit down the certain
rate and that determines the price of
Bitcoin and then you can use that
Bitcoin at different online websites or
maybe even like a credit card reader you
can actually use it like an app on your
phone like Apple pay I've heard though a
lot of people talk about mining
so mining just as a website means a
server to get up and running Bitcoin is
since it's not owned by any particular
person needs servers or computers all
around the world to make sure it works
so for example would be like Facebook
paying you to run a part of their
website off on your computer so that's
kind of what mining is so if I wanted to
buy like ten bitcoins how much would
that cost me $100,000 can I give you
some services and get bitcoins for it
depends on the service I can teach you
breakdance all right no I'm gonna teach
you a little stretch it's called the
turtle oh oh how many bitcoins ten
bitcoins 15 nothing is there any other
way for me to get a Bitcoin so you can
actually buy a fraction of a Bitcoin so
you can go to Quinn based comm just
enter in the dollar amount that you want
in Bitcoin and it'll be automatically
converted into Bitcoin all right guys
I'm gonna be honest I was gonna invest
BuzzFeed's money the budget that I have
for the video but the credit card was
declined
so just like any good investor I'm gonna
call my mom right now and ask her how
much of my own money
should put in I have a pretty important
question to ask you right now so I'm
about to invest in Bitcoin how much
money should I put in one hundred
dollars is safe will I become a
millionaire just for the sake of the
video can you say yes will I become a
millionaire
it's possible all right so I'm gonna put
in a hundred dollars if I if I lose the
money will you give me your money that
means you don't get my money if I win a
bunch of money all right I love you
all right point 0:09 bitcoins oh yeah
baby I can afford point all nine
bitcoins I'm gonna be a billionaire oh
my god oh my god I've invested in
Bitcoin I've invested in Bitcoin I have
bitcoins point zero zero nine eight
bitcoins baby parties oh yeah really
what the Bitcoin is that like a neo pet
currency no you gotta watch my video
guys this is so fun I understand that
one hundred dollars may not seem so
exciting but this has been really
educational it's really cool it's an
interesting topic I think everyone
should study like the market and try and
figure out what investing is I'm gonna
check back in tomorrow see how I'm doing
I'm gonna check one last time before I
go to bed I've already made five dollars
I made five dollars already it's been
ten minutes that's thirty dollars an
hour that's actually really good
[Music]
so I'm just gonna refresh real quick no
I know what's the dollars I can't look
at it I'm gonna go to bed we'll see what
happens tomorrow I love you good night
that was quick so obviously this video
needs an ending and I'm just gonna check
how much money I made off Bitcoin I have
made $13 what's important to take away
from this video is that there are a
bunch of different kinds of investments
Bitcoin is a very risky one as you can
see from this graph it really fluctuates
you can lose a lot of money if you put a
lot of money in but if you want to just
learn the market you can put a little
bit of money in experience it for
yourself just remember it's not a game
but it is fun I'm not gonna lie so I
hope you
I'm a millionaire one day good luck I'll
see you guys later
[Music]